hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by cove and
we will be reviewing
a what i eat in a day by alicia marie
now before we get into it a quick word
about my sponsor cove
so when i was pregnant with baby o i
suffered from
debilitating migraines pretty much
every day of the entire first trimester
that's a long time to feel like crap
i don't know if it was from exhaustion
dehydration or
just something else hormonal going on
but it was by far the
worst part of my pregnancy and since
this was all going down during covid
i really didn't feel like going for any
additional doctor's appointments or
seeing any specialists if i could avoid
it
so i wish i knew about this specialized
care service from cove
at the time because it probably would
have saved me
a massive well
headache so the way cove works is that
you go onto with cove.com
for a quick online consultation then a
licensed doctor will recommend a
specific treatment plan
uniquely for you and your headaches cove
delivers prescriptions
right to your door for as little as ten
dollars a month
and you don't have to worry about trying
to get see specialists
sitting in waiting rooms going to the
pharmacy
or running out of medication so i really
didn't realize how
common migraines were but apparently 39
million americans suffer from them
regularly
so if that sounds like you and you want
to streamline how you access specialized
care
you can head over to the link in my
description for an online consultation
and you can get 50 off of your first
month of medication
plus free two-day shipping so start 2021
off right
and have more migraine-free days with
cove
also you can pause the screen and look
at the description to check out my
disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
i will be talking macros and calories
so feel free to skip that portion if
that isn't supportive of your journey
and of course don't forget subscribe to
the channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss
out on a video alright so a little
background on alicia and her weight loss
journey
for such a young girl she's been through
quite a lot
four years ago she reports going through
an unhealthy restriction period
which she says resulted in some benching
tendencies
she later went vegan which actually
resulted in weight gain
and then in january 2019 she started the
regimen
she's on now which is based on a diet
from the celebrity nutritionist
dr goglia now goglia's g plan
offers a 15 question quiz to help you
find out your
metabolic type and then suggest
different weight loss strategies
depending on your results
now while i couldn't find any studies
cited on the website to
substantiate this outlandish concept i
did find
one small study looking at the metabolic
typing diet
which found that the results from the
questionnaire were
different from the actual lab tests
in other words this test is actual bs
obviously anyways according to alicia's
test results
she has a dual metabolism which
apparently means she can process carbs
fat and protein with equal efficiency
again totally bunk she now eats no dairy
gluten or yeast
and eats a relatively lower carb whole
food diet
so let's take a look at what that looks
like in quarantine times
also a quick reminder that this is just
a single video review and i'm
filming this a bit in advance as well so
it may not be reflective
of alicia's current daily diet like yo
i have been snacking more than i ever
have i'm trying just to remind myself to
be
gentle with myself i've also been trying
to find a balance where i let myself
splurge a little bit what i eat when i'm
trying to be still somewhat healthy
allowing me to have a little splurges
and not feel guilty about that because
food should
never make you feel guilty so i think
that this is the position
a lot of people find themselves in
during the past
year you know we're all thrown off of
our routines
and we may be without a lot of the
parties and social activities that we're
used
to so food has become one of our
major life pleasures i know that like
baking something delicious or ordering a
special meal for my favorite restaurant
is definitely what i look forward to
each week
and while i don't love the clean eating
rhetoric that i hear from her
i can appreciate that this is kind of
just how people talk these days
and at least she's taking a gentler
approach to her diet
and exercise in these unprecedented
times
let's see what she's gonna have to eat
lately i've actually been really
obsessed with
a berry smoothie literally just vanilla
protein powder mixed berries of
yo choi like a beet powder it's super
healthy for you and some almond butter
oh my god and here's our homemade
smoothie bowl
okay so that looks great and it is
inherently
perfectly balanced we've got protein
in the protein powder we've got fiber
rich carbs from the berries
and some healthy fats in the almond
butter now
she mentioned adding in some beet powder
which
i've actually done some experimenting
with myself in my house
mainly for the natural sweet flavor it
has and the pretty pink
color that adds to like smoothies and
pancakes and muffins
but beef powder like this one from sweet
elite
is often used as a pre-workout because
it's a source of nitric oxide
so nitric oxide helps enhance blood flow
and decreases the amount of oxygen your
body needs during exercise
and some small studies suggest that beet
juice
may help slightly decrease the amount of
aerobic energy
used in exercise now i'm not sure if she
was going to work out after this
but if so this would be a good
light first morning meal let's see
what's for snack and we have a lot of
bananas that look like they're gonna go
bad so i think i'm gonna have
one of those snacking is like the number
one thing that helps me not binge at
night for me personally like that is my
biggest thing that helps with cravings
or
like overeating sometimes is just like
making sure i eat enough snacks
throughout the day
so i 100 agree and it doesn't have to be
snacks but rather just making sure that
you eat enough
in the day will help prevent binges
later on
at night i know right now it's trendy to
go like long periods between meals but
for a lot of people
myself included snacking or having small
meals throughout the day may help you
better tune into your hunger
and fullness cues and keep those energy
levels nice and stable
and a banana is a fine choice if you're
craving something light
but i would say that if she want to bump
up the satiety factor
especially if this was a post-workout
snack
she could pair that banana with some nut
butter nuts
or a few hard-boiled eggs let's see
what's for lunch
so today we're making our own like diy
chipotle these are
just riced cauliflower flavor got
seasoning is one of my favorite
very low sodium season like lately oh my
god it's so good
chicken's bomb uh yum this looks awesome
love me a diy chipotle bowl
so we've got protein in the chicken
healthy fats in the guacamole
and lots of fiber rich produce in the
cauliflower rice
and tomatoes i also love that she kind
of gussied up the frozen cauliflower
rice with some citrus
and herbs which is like really a great
way to
boost nutrition and flavor it is a lower
carb lunch for sure so she could add in
some real rice or corn or black beans
or even some baked tortilla chips but
she did have more carbs for breakfast
and snack so in the context of the day
and the fact that it sounds like she
just prefers a lower carb diet
i think we're balanced out just fine
let's see what's next i made some coffee
i made an oat milk latte
this has been the number one thing that
i feel like i've been
really splurging on big ol like oat milk
latte
i also love me a good oat milk latte but
i 100 agree that if there's something in
your routine that just
makes your day you definitely should try
to keep it in your diet
and work the rest of your day around it
but i'm not sure i would count
a little oat milk as a splurge
i mean like she didn't even put sugar in
it so it's not like she's having a daily
venti frappuccino
now i get that everyone's goals are
unique and i also
generally agree that drinking your
calories when you're trying to lose
weight
isn't the best strategy but still
i think that there's room for you to
have your coffee how you like it
even on days you're trying to be strict
with your diet that little oat milk
latte
is probably not going to make or break
your health moving on so one of my
favorite freaking snacks is just
cucumber some tahini on it
all i'm gonna say about this is if you
know you
know forgot we still have the leftover
guac from lunch oh my god so
boom i
do in fact know a good recipe with tahin
as it's actually the most popular recipe
on the abby's kitchen blog
my watermelon fries so i'm gonna leave a
link to that bad boy
below girl you should check it out i
think you're gonna love it but also i
agree that cucumber is also a great
vessel for that seasoning mix as well
tahin
and while cucumber on its own isn't
really a legit
snack to me serving it with the
guacamole
definitely helps to bump up the satiety
factor a bit
and i think that would be an awesome
pair actually i often add a little
sprinkle of tahini
to my guacamole and it is
good let's take a look at her next snack
i just have some carrots and a
hard-boiled egg keep the perfect
hard-boiled egg from the hard-boiled egg
cooker it's a perfect
medium boiled okay bye so this girl like
eats like me and everyone's always like
oh my god you're eating again
honestly but if snacking or like grazing
feels good to her and her body then
great
and also a hard-boiled egg is an
excellent source of protein to pair with
the fiber rich veg so that looks like a
pretty great snack to me
let's hit up dinner we've been obsessed
with spaghetti squash we have a
healthier
sauce we've also been obsessed with
ground turkey lately homemade
meatballs these are also turkey honestly
looks great smells great um we've been a
big fan of this that looks incredible i
mean
we've got some fat and protein in the
sauce and the meatballs
we have fiber in the spaghetti squash
it's definitely a lower carb meal again
but since weight loss or at least weight
management
is on alicia's radar i think that the
spaghetti
squash swap is a really great hack
it's loaded with fiber and vitamin c and
has around 40 calories a cup
compared with regular wheat pasta which
would be over
200 but for most people i would say
there's definitely room to add in
a little bit more carbs either like a
piece of bread for sopping up that sauce
or going half seas with real pasta
and the squash let's see what's next
these are called honey mamas
remy introduced us to these so
freaking good they're just these little
chocolate bars that i'm like
okay so i know i just mentioned adding a
little carb at dinner
but having a sweet dessert is another
way to kind of balance out
a lower carb meal now let's not say that
you can't have carbs at dinner and
dessert
but if lower carb meals work for alicia
but she still wants to have
a little some something i think that it
does make sense to kind of shift things
around
to accommodate some chocolate at the end
of the day
before bed i always have a little fruit
okay i think i'm gonna go for
some dates because i freaking
freaking love i also love dates and
again
i think having those lower carb meals
makes sense in the context of her higher
carb snacks as for her doctor's
suggestion to have fruit before bed
well it kind of depends on what kind of
fruit
for one some fruits like kiwi and tart
cherries
have been shown in research to have
sleep benefits
but i haven't been able to find anything
specific on dates
or on fruit in general one study did
find that consuming refined
carbohydrates that are higher on the
glycemic index
increase the likelihood of insomnia
while fiber-rich
whole foods did not so while dates are
rich in natural sugars
there's actually about three grams of
fiber in two dates to help slow it down
so it is considered a low glycemic index
food
and if she wanted to modify that effect
even more
she could fill her date with a little
nut butter and that would make the
glycemic load even lower
alrighty folks trigger warning i'm about
to talk numbers
but let's wrap this up so according to
our calculations
alicia is consuming around 1800 calories
with
28 of those calories coming from protein
38
from carbs and about 34 from fat
so definitely a lower carb higher fat
higher protein
day and if that's what's working for her
amazing
sounds good to me now she is a little
low in a few
key nutrients like omega-3s vitamin d
calcium folate and iron but these are
really common nutrients to be low in
and are easy ones to supplement as
needed now let's talk about what i
like in this day so i love that even
though alicia is on her own
weight loss journey she's including a
variety of
little pleasures throughout her day like
the chocolate bar
the oat milk latte and the dates and
while she eats a
lower carb diet she seems to genuinely
enjoy the foods that she makes
and eats i also find her recipes to be
pretty accessible and easy to prepare
and there generally isn't a lot of
outrageous expensive ingredients
or products in her day now let's talk
about some
gentle nutrition tips so i have to give
it to alicia i think her diet is
generally well balanced and considering
her goal is
weight loss or weight maintenance i
don't find it
overly restrictive in calories like we
see from a lot of other young women
now if i were to make any suggestions i
would probably try to suggest
adding some dark leafy greens to her day
to help her meet her needs from folate
vitamin k and iron so that could mean
wilting some spinach into a pasta or
throwing a handful of kale into her
smoothie
which i have actually seen her do in
other videos
and while her omega-3s were a little low
this day she normally does eat a lot of
salmon
as well as protein balls with some
ground flax in them but also walnuts or
hemp hearts would also be some really
easy
sources to like throw into some snacks
as well now let's talk about her
relationship with food
as discussed in her intro it seems like
despite being on a weight loss journey
alicia is being kind to herself in these
unusual coveted times
and is prioritizing her mental health
over really pushing hard on her weight
loss goals
i think this is really great advice for
everyone but i also want to flag that
this thinking
should not be limited to a pandemic i
get that there are going to be times in
your life where you feel up to
kind of eating more clean as she says
and a pandemic is
probably not one of those times but i
think if we can take
anything away from this experience it
might be some basic
self-care strategies and if having oat
milk in your damn latte
sparks joy shouldn't that be worked into
your plan
long term honestly those little life
pleasures are the key
to being able to stick to your health
resolutions for life
not just drop like a few pounds and then
regain it over and over again
when your willpower dries up i've also
heard her say that she honors her hunger
and fullness cues
and listens to her body if she doesn't
feel up to working out
having said that this does seem to be a
change of pace for alicia whose previous
videos featured a lot of diet culture
rhetoric
and a bit of misinformation so the whole
metabolism blood test is one example
and i know that she uses a lot of
language around cheat meals and clean
eating
that you know that i don't love in
another video sponsored by noom
which i have a whole video unpacking
right here
she talks about how she used to make too
many excuses
to not work out or to not eat clean
which i think
kind of contradicts a lot of her most
recent sentiments
about being kind to yourself during
coven so i'm hoping that this speaks to
some growth and evolution in her journey
and that she's shifting her attitude
around her body and well-being
to being one framed better by self-care
in conclusion i think alicia is one of
the more moderate
la gen zed lifestyle youtubers in that
clan
when it comes to weight loss advice and
i'm glad that she's finding a way of
eating
that balances her health goals with her
mental sanity in a pandemic
my hope is that she can continue to
build on these acts of body kindness
even after the pandemic and find a way
of eating that feels good to her
long term and on that note that is all
that i have for you guys today
thank you again to co for sponsoring if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with who you'd
like to see me review next subscribe to
the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you